when Russia invaded Afghanistan we
didn't ask what's the best option for
Russia the best option for them is to
get out you know they have no right
being there so the best options to get
out when Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait
we didn't ask what's the best option
like how should he deal with that but
when the West invades another country
all the values shift the only question
that arises is what's best for the
aggressors well that's interesting you
know it's a sign of the deeply rooted
Imperial mentality which of course goes
back centuries and virtually dominates
the intellectual and moral cultures but
in the case of Iraq we should recognize
the principles that we automatically
accept when someone else is guilty of a
crime the aggressors simply have no
rights they have responsibilities but no
rights the primary responsibility is
written in the United States is to pay
massive reparations for the crimes that
they've committed that includes the
invasion of course it includes the
murderers sanctions regime the directors
of the UN oil-for-food program
distinguished international diplomats
both resigns because they regarded it as
genocide it includes support for saddam
hussein through his worst atrocities
long after the end of the war with iran
in fact even after the first Gulf War
when President Bush the first authorized
Saddam to crush the rebellion internal
rebellions that probably would have
overthrown it well massive reparations
are certainly called for second
responsibility is to hold the guilty
accountable and the third
responsibilities pay attention to the
voices of the victims and we have a
pretty good sense of what they are
doesn't enter into debate so if you look
at the presidential debates or the
discussion of the options that one voice
is missing Iraqis and it's not that the
voice is not heard the Pentagon and
December released its latest study of
focus groups all around Iraq and it
presented its report as an optimistic
report that said there's good news
Iraqis have shared beliefs so there's
hope for reconciliation contrary to what
is said by people who think that the
sectarian violence is out of control and
look down and see what the shared
beliefs are the shared beliefs are that
the United States is responsible for the
sectarian violence and the other crimes
and that the invaders ought to pull out
and leave the country for the Iraqis
that's the shared beliefs that's the
good news
well that position does not enter into
discussion in the West it's reported
that's forgotten because it doesn't
matter we run the world we own the world
we decide what's best I can have my own
opinion oh we ought to do others can
have their own equally uninformed
opinions including the CIA and military
intelligence but what matters is what
Iraqis want and we should give them the
opportunity to construct policy by
Iraqis I do not mean the government that
is established in the highly protected
heavily protected us run green zone yeah
it's there but that's not the voice of
Iraqis any more than the government that
the Russians said we're protecting and
Kabul in the 1980s was the voice of
Afghans so those are the
responsibilities from then on we have to
follow those obligations I don't think
there's any good solution for Iraq at
this point the United States says it's
kind of interesting to see that although
Americans and Europeans do not accept
the principles that they profess Iraqis
do when Iraqis accuse attribute
responsibility to the invaders for the
murderous sectarian violence they are
simply following the principles of the
or tribunal then or tribunal quite
explicitly defined aggression in terms
which of course trivially applied to the
u.s. British invasion of Iraq and went
on to say that aggression is the supreme
international crime the differing from
other war crimes in that it encompasses
all of the evil that follows well in the
case of Iraq that means it encompasses
the sectarian murderous sectarian
warfare the ethnic cleansing and so on
and Iraqis accept that they accept the
Nuremberg principle says Pentagon
studies shows Americans and Europeans
don't accept that we don't accept that
we were that we the aggressors are
responsible for all the evil that
follows and again as a reflection of the
Imperial mentality we can profess
principles but they only apply to others
not to us we should live up to those
principles should mention finally that
the chief prosecutor at Nuremberg
Justice Robert Jackson American
prosecutor had some eloquent words that
he addressed to the tribunal he said we
are handing this of courses the tribunal
that tried the the worst Nazi war
criminals it said we are handing these
defendants of poison chalice and if we
sit from it if we were ever guilty of
similar crimes we must accept the same
judgment or else we are declaring the
trial to be a farce
well European and American opinion
tacitly is that the trials were forced
it's not the first time
Iraqis appeared but maybe probably don't
know it but they're the in fact are
accepting the Nuremberg principles we
should think about the possibility of
living up to our own professed ideals
which means applying them to ourselves
it could be a very different world if we
did that the same would be true about
let's let's take the next it with regard
to Iraq Iraqis and knowledgeable
correspondents like say NIR Rosen was
followed it very closely from the
beginning they often describe the
American British Invasion as comparable
to the Mongol invasions of the 13th
century it's not clear that there is any
solution for Iraq the only question is
what's the least worse solution at this
point that nobody has a positive
proposal as to what to do but it's up to
Iraqis to determine it
the next major potential conflict with
Iran it could be even more serious if
Bush Cheney or maybe their successors go
on to attack Iran or to permit Israel
their client state to attack Iran that
could be extremely serious early Barnett
might be correct and it's interesting to
notice that of course the Iranian
opinion doesn't matter world opinion
doesn't matter the world is appalled by
the prospect but it's striking to see
that American opinion doesn't matter
either there have been careful studies
of American and Iranian opinion on the
outstanding issues between Iran and the
United States carried out by the most
prestigious polling agencies and the
results are quite striking Americans and
Iranians fundamentally agree on the core
issues the nuclear issues large
majorities very large majorities in both
countries agree that Iran has the same
rights as other signers of the
non-proliferation treaty that is the
right to nuclear energy but not nuclear
power us reject government rejects that
the large majority of Americans accept
that more interestingly large majorities
agree that the entire region including
Iran Israel forces deployed there should
be declared a nuclear weapons free zone
that's quite significant if that
happened the crisis would significantly
mitigate maybe be overcome and a very
large majority of Americans it's about
three to one I think that the United
States should end
the threats against Iran and move
towards normal diplomatic relations
well the opinion of Americans shared by
Iranians is so remote from policy that
these poles aren't even reported and of
course the results never enter into
political debate or discussion every
viable political candidate now every
surviving candidate I believe that we
must but as they put it keep all options
on the table including threat of
military action against Iran even the
threat happens to be a violation of
international law but it's quite
striking that they're all quite willing
to take a position violation of
international law and overwhelmingly
opposed by the American population I
mean what this is not the only case I
should say I mean take say the u.s.
policy you know 45 years of first
large-scale terror then economic
strangulation of Cuba I mean ever since
polls have been taken which is several
decades a large majority of Americans
think that the United States should
enter into normal relations with Cuba
and end the confrontation but this just
doesn't enter policy I mean going back
to Iran if Iran and the United States
were functioning democracies meaning the
democracies in which popular opinion
plays a significant role in determining
public policy then the confrontation
would probably would surely be mitigated
and might be overcome those that's
another seeking
serious problem in the West's internal
are we going to be functioning
democracies in which public opinion
matters or not and it doesn't only show
up on international affairs when it
takes a the United States will take
domestic issues for decades the one of
the leading domestic issues for the
population has been the health care
system which is catastrophic as twice
the per capita costs of other industrial
societies and some of the worst outcomes
often
third-world standards aside from 47
million people with no insurance and the
many millions who are underinsured so
the population unlike least naturally
and they have a preference namely for a
national health care system maybe
something like extending Medicare to the
whole population well up until that's
very interesting to see how that's
handled in the intellectual culture and
the media and the political system as
late as 2004 the last election this was
occasionally mentioned but it was
regarded as politically impossible or
lacking political support those are the
words that are used only had the support
of the large majority of the population
but that's not political support in this
election for the first time 2008 it's
become an issue I mean the Democratic
candidates at least have put forth
proposals which approach what the
general population wants what's changed
between 2004 and 2008 not public opinion
it's the same what's changed is that a
major sector of the corporate system is
now objecting to the irrationality
expense in efficiency of the privatized
health care system namely manufacturing
industry the General Motors says it
costs them over a thousand dollars more
to produce a car in Detroit than it does
across the border and Windsor Canada
where they have a functioning health
care system well when a sector of when a
major sector of corporate power enters
the game then it becomes politically
possible it tells us a lot about
American democracy as does the fact that
there's no reporting on it try to find
some mention of the chain the reason for
the change well these are all internal
problems in the West
serious ones I mean there's enormous
problem much more serious problems of
functioning democracy elsewhere in the
world of course but even in the
industrial West there's plenty to be
concerned about these were also matters
of significance
it's a matter of significance for
example that the poorest country in
South America namely Bolivia
had an election which reached a level of
democratic of authentic democratic
participation that we can't even dream
of population was engaged that the
majority were serious people know what
the issues were
they'd been struggling about for years
not just on voting day they elected
someone from their own ranks who was
committed to significant issues that the
population had majority the population
decided were their own it really doesn't
happen in western elections certainly
not in u.s. elections those are things
we should be concerned about too